[Musique]
les anciens fumeurs c'est quand même le
cigare ça peut sentir quand même un peu
fort s'il vous plaît ah bon nous sommes
à l'antenne même les barbelés autour de
ce petit aéroport régional protégeant
les pistes ne l'ont pas arrêté dans sa
course folle cet ours brun dévale la
ville de sapporo et sèment le chaos une
attaque dans une rue résidentielle
puis une autre à travers les grilles de
cette caserne militaire bien jeunes
requins tic de 3 mètres 50 qui vient
vous renifler la zone à côté de laquelle
je suis est pour lui une bonne manière
de me faire comprendre que je suis pas
le bienvenu c'est d'effectuer un tour à
90° et de me mettre en cause à tout
gentil l'ours s'était sans doute
aventuré en ville pour chercher à manger
parce que son habitat la forêt se
dégrade
mais un petit peu de boucliers au coude
le requin tape le coup mais ça s'arrête
là
on comprend que moi aussi je maintient
une distance et j'ai compris que lui
doit pas impossible à maîtriser est trop
agressif selon les autorités il a
finalement été abattu par des chasseurs
autres conséquences du dérèglement
climatique
un hiver trop d'où les souris continue
de se reproduire par milliers à la nuit
tombée des hordes de rongeurs envahi si
les exploitations les agriculteurs
désemparé tente de les freiner par tous
les moyens
ici un piège de fortune pour les noyer
leur a sonné
les montpelliérains doivent à nouveau
mettre le masque dans la rue on va leur
mettre alors pourquoi pas le matin c'est
complètement
excusez moi mais c'est débile complet
moi je le garderais parce que c'est une
sécurité
il ya trop de risque risk exactement si
on accélère le rythme et qu'on va de
plus en plus vite on risque de retomber
peut-être dans un confinement
donc pour moi un emploi mais il n'ya pas
que dans les grandes villes que cette
décision s'applique à saint guilhem le
désert
l'un des plus beaux villages de france
qui attire de nombreux touristes
on doit désormais porter le masque tous
les jours on a tendance à mettre le
masque naturellement quand il ya du
monde là si on n'avait pas été prévenu
on l'aurait pas mis clairement leur ai
pas mis encore longtemps encore
la voilà ok regardez
[Musique]
- blessés par jour par la police depuis
le 1er janvier
voyez le 7 janvier à mort le troc
janvier deux morts un blessé le 9
janvier encore un tabac c'est sur ce
terrain pour marquer quand même rigolé
vous pouvez pas mettre sur la balance
disons un policier qui fait son devoir
c'est le terme et tire toujours sur un
arabe en tombant derrière dans le dos
l'évacuation a été facilité selon ce
tweet du ministère de l'intérieur par la
saisie provisoire des matériels utilisés
sur les photos le matériel en question
où il y apparaît pour le moins abîmée
ces images d'amateurs tourné hier semble
montrer qu'il ne s'agissait pas d'une
simple saisie mais plutôt d'une
destruction
leur but ce n'est pas de couper le son
c'était de détruire le sont et ils ont
ils ont transpercé les les haut parleurs
ils ont cassé les platines ils ont tout
détruit
alors était ce légal il était pas
envisageable de saisir le matériel cassé
parce qu'il a été neutralisée au café il
a été neutralisé en comprend toujours
les choses lorsqu'il est trop tard
les gens se rendront compte à quel point
berlin a changé quand il n'existera plus
de lieux dédiés à l'épanouissement
personnel
mais bientôt tout sera remplacé par le
consumérisme tous les endroits de la
ville vont finir par se ressembler c'est
ça que nous voulons
le seul cas dans lequel il est possible
que du matériel ou des biens soient
détruits avant un jugement
c'est sur décision du procureur de la
république quand ces biens sont
dangereux nuisibles ou illicite ce qui
n'est absolument pas le cas s'agissant
de matériel de sonorisation
on est donc dans une description
totalement illégales de la part des
forces de l'ordre
une plaisanterie sans toi c'est bien sûr
tant que résident ici en trois
dimensions vous en sait pas plus
rose
une façon je tiens la barre
je vous ai jamais fait que suivre c'est
pas compliqué on n'est pas là
[Musique]
et
tu n'as pas
[Applaudissements]
chirac et son fils m'a pas trop de
policiers avec moi en train d'écouter
quelque chose de dieu le père rudy
[Musique]
justement paie sa caméra
est ce que j'aimerais vous appeler pour
une fois dans ma vie peuvent prétendre
et parce que je vous appelle vous
attendez le président de l'acro nous
tout à fait apparemment tout le monde et
c'est jusqu'au dès ce matin j'ai été
interpellé par ces gens parce que
j'avais un gilet jaune dans ma poche
justement mulhousien emmanuel macron
landais je ne sais pas si j'aurai
l'occasion de lui parler il a il a
tellement mépriser les légers les jaunes
je suis gilet jaune à la base pour
voulez vous qu'on ne soit pas en colère
avec tout ce qui se passe c'est la vie
c'est la vie c'est le tien avec raymond
s'il a toujours vive la vie vive l'amour
c'est la vie qui vous appelle
c'est louise était qui fait chanter la
joie quand ou vittek tout va en un mot
la vie est belle pour vous et pour moi
merci charles trenet merci on va
terminer là dessus